[Música]
como una gran noticia para el pueblo
estadounidense así calificó el
presidente Joe en la aprobación en el
congreso del proyecto de ley que
suspende el techo de la deuda en el país
el mandatario agradeció a los líderes
del Congreso que según él actuaron
responsablemente biden sancionará la ley
este sábado
Panamá lanzó la llamada operación chocó
que comprende desplegar 1200 agentes en
la zona del Darién fronteriza con
Colombia para enfrentar a las bandas
criminales que afectan a migrantes por
la zona han cruzado más de 166 mil
migrantes en situación irregular en lo
que va de 2023
el presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro
retiró de sus cargos a la jefa de
gabinete y al embajador en Venezuela
tras un escándalo por presuntas
intimidaciones ordenadas Contra quién
era la cuidadora del hijo de la
funcionaria en las que resultó
involucrado el ahora ex embajador en
Venezuela
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos damos inicio en
Estados Unidos donde este sábado el
presidente Joe biden sancionará el
proyecto de ley que suspende el techo de
la deuda en el país en un discurso
televisado desde la Casa Blanca del
mandatario aseguró que con la aprobación
de la iniciativa por parte de ambas
cámaras del congreso se evitó caer en
default lo que según biden habría sido
catastrófico además agradeció a los
líderes del legislativo de quienes dijo
actuaron responsablemente
la aprobación de este acuerdo
presupuestario fue fundamental lo que
estaba en juego no podría haber sido más
alto hubo voces extremas que amenazaron
de no haber podido llegar a un acuerdo
sobre el presupuesto conllevar a Estados
Unidos por primera vez en nuestros 247
años de historia al incumplimiento de
pago de nuestra deuda nacional nada nada
hubiera sido más irresponsable nada
hubiera sido más catastrófico
era fundamental llegar a un acuerdo y
son muy buenas noticias para el pueblo
estadounidense nadie obtuvo lo que
quería pero el pueblo estadounidense
obtuvo lo que necesitaba evitamos una
crisis económica un colapso económico
estamos recortando el gasto y reduciendo
los déficit al mismo tiempo
el gobierno de Canadá está enviando
personal militar para ayudar a combatir
los incendios forestales en la provincia
nororiental de Nueva Escocia otawa pide
ayuda a su vecino del sur y se espera
que bomberos estadounidenses se sumen a
las tareas unos 28.000 canadienses se
han visto obligados a evacuar a sus
hogares
el mayor incendio forestal jamás
registrado en Nueva Escocia bajo este
espeso manto de un muy ceniza la ciudad
de barrington en la costa este de Canadá
se está asfixiando mientras los grandes
incendios forestales arrasan la
provincia el gobierno canadiense ha
enviado al ejército y ha pedido ayuda a
los bomberos estadounidenses según las
autoridades Es probable que los
incendios se iniciaran accidentalmente
por la actividad humana antes de
propagarse debido a las condiciones de
calor sequedad y viento hasta el jueves
por la noche unos 200 edificios habían
quedado destruidos 18.000 personas
habían sido evacuadas y decenas de miles
de hectáreas se convirtieron en humo
creo que es un momento estresante está
llevando un tiempo considerable hablé
con uno de nuestros bomberos y me dijo
que puede pisar una brasa y no se
apagará puede pisarla y retroceder y
vuelve a encenderse tienes que aplicar
agua es muy muy seco Mientras tanto al
oeste del país escenas similares como
helicópteros y bomberos luchan para
controlar las llamas bajo un cielo de
humo rojo la provincia de Alberta ha
declarado el de emergencia ya que los
incendios han arrasado sus bosques
durante más de un mes actualmente hay 61
incendios forestales en la zona de
protección forestal de Alberta 15 de los
cuales están fuera de control en lo que
va de año hemos respondido a 555
incendios que han quemado más de un
millón 120.000 hectáreas Canadá es
testigo de los incendios forestales más
frecuentes y graves a medida que se
acelera el cambio climático el país
tiene actualmente 200 incendios
forestales Ardiendo en siete de sus 10
provincias las autoridades panameñas
lanzaron operativo para combatir a los
grupos criminales que atacan a migrantes
en la selva del Darién zona que conecta
a Colombia con su vecino del Norte la
denominada operación chocó contará con
el despliegue de 1200 agentes en el
Darién para frenar la presencia de
bandas armadas internacionales Max Pérez
Gallardo nos amplía
Panamá fortifica el tapón del Darién
1200 tropas serán desplegadas en la
selva del Darién por el gobierno
panameño con el objetivo de combatir la
presencia de grupos criminales que
violentan a los migrantes que transitan
por la frontera natural del país con
Colombia la operación chocó el resultado
de un esfuerzo conjunto del servicio
Nacional de Migración y el servicio
nacional de fronteras que tiene como
objetivo principal diezmar las
operaciones ilegales
todo el entramado del tráfico de
migrantes en este momento lo está
maniobrando articulando y desarrollando
específicamente nuestros informes de
inteligencia la organización
narcoterrorista clan del golfo del lado
colombiano en los primeros meses del
2023 aproximadamente 166 mil migrantes
han cruzado por la selva del Darién
convirtiéndola en uno de los pasos
migratorios más importantes del
continente sin embargo el peligro que
representa el terreno selvático aumenta
las condiciones climáticas extremas y la
presencia de traficantes de personas
hacen del daría en un infierno para los
migrantes 60 decesos no tengo el número
Exacto pero van más de 60 decesos Yo sé
que en estas dos una semana y media
hubieron como 10 10 decesos fue por las
inundaciones la alza de los ríos y
muchas personas se ahogaron según
estimaciones del gobierno de Panamá se
espera que aproximadamente 400.000
personas crucen el tapón del Dari en
este año lo que duplicaría el flujo de
personas que pasaron por la selva en
2022 en otras noticias vamos a Colombia
donde el viernes el presidente Gustavo
Petro retiró del cargo a su jefa de
gabinete y al embajador en Venezuela
tras un escándalo por presuntas
interceptaciones telefónicas ordenadas
Contra quién era la cuidadora del hijo
de la funcionaria y en las que resultó
involucrado el ahora ex embajador en
Venezuela Marina sardina con los
detalles
un robo un polígrafo presuntas escuchas
telefónicas ilegales los escándalos de
la última semana en el seno del
ejecutivo colombiano hacen temblar la
casa de nariño con el retiro de las dos
personas de mayor confianza del
presidente Gustavo Petro Laura Sarabia
su jefa de gabinete y mano derecha y el
embajador de Colombia en Venezuela
Armando Benedetti y funcionaria querida
y estimada y el embajador de Venezuela
se retiran del gobierno para que desde
el poder que implica esos cargos no se
pueda tener ni siquiera la desconfianza
de que se va a alterar los procesos de
investigación que no nos corresponden a
nosotros
le corresponden a las autoridades
competentes por ahí Sarabia de 29 años
sometió al polígrafo a la niñera de su
hijo tras un robo en su casa que la
fiscalía está investigando la misma fue
también empleada de Benedetti quien es
señalado de estar detrás de la denuncia
de la trabajadora que además habría sido
víctima de escuchas ilegales en un país
donde el mismo Petro fue víctima de las
también conocidas como chuzadas durante
el gobierno del ultraderechista Álvaro
Uribe Pues la verdad que en Colombia
esto has tenido consecuencias tenebrosas
porque organismos de inteligencia
incluso organismos del propio poder
ejecutivo practicaron durante décadas
estos métodos de infiltración de
intersecciones telefónicas pero
consecuencias fatales ha sido un
instrumento de guerra tanto Benedetti
como Sarabia trabajaron juntos para
llevar a Petro a la presidencia pero ya
en la casa de nariño dicen comenzaron
los por cargos en El Ejecutivo ambos
presentaron su renuncias al mandatario
agradezco su respaldo siempre su lealtad
y su voto de confianza cada día
agradezco presidente Gustavo Petro la
confianza que me brindaste al designarme
una de las más importantes tareas para
tu gobierno restablecer las relaciones
entre Colombia y Venezuela lo logramos
el fiscal general señaló que se tomarán
decisiones judiciales por el caso de las
también conocidas como chuzadas mientras
Petro intenta salvarse a sí mismo en un
momento en el que su popularidad está en
declive en Ecuador el presidente
Guillermo lasso anunció que no se
presentará a las elecciones anticipadas
del 20 de agosto el mandatario aseguró
que su decisión Busca proteger la
democracia en el país actualmente lazo
gobierna por decreto esto tras decretar
la figura constitucional conocida como
muerte Cruzada con la que disolvió la
asamblea nacional
después de una profunda reflexión
quiero anunciarles que no aceptaré la
postulación a la presidencia de la
república para las elecciones de agosto
para este gobierno
el trabajo no se detiene
al contrario
se va a redoblar no tiene ningún sentido
para mí
hacer campaña cuando el país me necesita
dedicado a los ciudadanos cuando hay aún
metas por alcanzar y desafíos que
superar fin de El informativo gracias
por su sintonía
[Música]